das gehirn manipulieren oder aber
gedanken auslesen noch klingt das nach
science-fiction pur
doch schon in wenigen jahren soll die
technik solche dinge möglich machen wir
menschen werden uns in eine mischung aus
mensch und maschine verwandeln und
natürliche und künstliche intelligenz
werden verschmelzen nicht nur ihnen musk
und seine firma link haben diese vision
auch in deutschland gibt es firmen die
sich mit solchen visionen beschäftigen
klicks ums hans im future gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktive
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen
dieses video ist in zusammenarbeit mit
technology review entstanden dem
technologie magazin des m it dem
massachusetts institute for technology
und am ende gibt es ein exemplar für
euch kostenlos
das gerät ist gerade einmal so groß wie
ein feuerzeug und solch oder ein
vergleichbares elektroden set befindet
sich schon jetzt im gehirn von rund
80.000 parkinson patienten und
patientinnen
das ganze kann man sich in etwa so
vorstellen wie einen gehirn
schrittmacher der elektrische impulse in
tiefe hirnregionen leitet in den schädel
der patienten patienten wird ein loch
gebohrt damit die elektroden in den
tiefen regionen des gehirns ihren platz
finden befestigt werden sie an der
schädeldecke von wo aus ein kabel zum
brustbereich herunter führt denn dort
befindet sich die steuereinheit des
gehirn schrittmacher solch ein
elektroden set hat die deutsche firma
kottek entwickelt und es endet impulse
aus durch die elektroden werden diese
dann ins gehirn der betroffenen geleitet
bewegungsstörungen unter den parkinson
betroffenen leiden werden so gemindert
oder verschwinden sogar ganz
beispielsweise das zittern in der
fachsprache wird das zittern als tremor
bezeichnet parkinson erkrankte leiden
sehr darunter
häufig tritt ein langsames und
einseitiges zittern der hände auf und
später zittern auch die füße in den
meisten fällen ist das der fall wenn die
betroffenen sich ruhig verhalten
parkinson ist eine erkrankung des
zentralen nervensystems und gilt
übrigens bis heute als nicht teilbar
noch solche technologien wie
beispielsweise die elektroden sets der
freiburger firma können eine große hilfe
für die
sein denn hirnschrittmacher können
individuell gestaltet werden und kommen
nicht nur bei parkinson betroffenen zum
einsatz sondern auch bei chronischen
schmerz patientinnen und patienten sowie
bei depressiven in der vergangenheit
musste eine ärztin oder ein arzt her um
die abstände und intensitäten der
stimulation einzustellen dort zum
tatsächlichen bedürfnisse der
betroffenen passt das in den wenigsten
fällen hundertprozentig und so tüftelt
die freiburger firma korrekt daran dass
das system selbst weiß wann und wie
stark stimuliert werden muss
das system könnte dann also
selbstständig gegensteuern wenn der
tremor heftig wird oder aber die
betroffenen starken schmerz verspüren
während der schlafenszeiten der
parkinson erkrankten dagegen ist nur
wenig oder gar keine stimulation
notwendig dazu der geschäftsführer von
contact martin schüttler wir dagegen
entwickeln derzeit ein system das die
signale interpretiert und sich
selbstständig anpasst das core tech
gerät soll also auch im alltag zu
verwenden seien und so sollen daten die
übertragen werden per hochfrequenz
übertragungen gesendet werden denn die
kabelverbindung stellen ein risiko für
die patientinnen und patienten da vor
allem an der durchtritt stelle drohen
entzündung aufgeladen werden die
elektroden setzt dann durch induktion
von außen auf der webseite der
verwaistes wir stellen alle lösungen
bereit um mit dem gehirn oder anderen
teilen des nervensystems zu
kommunizieren und genau das ist der
stand der technik wie sie heute ist die
deutsche firma covec baut sozusagen die
brücke zwischen dem neurologie
patientinnen und patienten und dem
cyborg allen masc ist dahingehend mit
seinen visionen schon deutlich weiter
typisch für ihn
er will das menschliche gehirn mit
maschinen verknüpfen und das reibungslos
dazu hat er seine firma neuling
geschaffen denn für ihn steht fest dass
wir menschen bereits jetzt den kampf
gegen die künstliche intelligenz
verloren haben seiner festen überzeugung
nach bleibt uns nur eine chance um zu
überleben und die zukunft mitzugestalten
jedem us befürchtet ansonsten eine
apokalypse er befürchtet nämlich dass
sich die künstliche intelligenz als
übermacht herausstellen wird mit hilfe
von eurer link also versucht er die
gesamte menschheit vor dem aussterben zu
retten erinnert immer wieder daran dass
im laufe der evolution die weniger
intelligente spezies durch die insel
ältere verdrängt worden ist seiner
vision zufolge könnten wir schon in
einigen wenigen jahren elektronische
geräte direkt mit unserem gehirn
verbinden und zwar mit hilfe
implantierter chips im gehirn die bits
und bytes in gedanken über setzen können
und umgekehrt dank eines gehirn
interfaces könnten wir alle dann nicht
nur viel schneller mit einer menschen
sondern auch mit anderen computern
interagieren und das quasi per
elektronischer gedankenübertragung sein
ziel ein echter ki mensch doch so weit
ist die forschung nicht noch nicht noch
lassen sich weder gedanken auslesen noch
das gehirn zuverlässig manipulieren doch
forschungsteams aus aller welt
offenbaren immer wieder auf ein neues
das hirn stimulation bereits jetzt in
der lage sind menschen zu verändern in
einem versuch kalifornischer fachleute
gelang es die probandinnen und probanden
kreativer zu machen und zwar um exakt 7
prozent dazu wurden elektroden in einem
gehirnbereich implantiert der sowohl für
tiefes denken als auch für tagträumen
entscheiden ist der us-forscher vettel
hat es geschafft seine versuchs
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
risikofreudiger zu machen ohne dass
seine probandinnen und probanden diese
veränderung bemerkt dazu schon battle
sie waren sich bei einer manipulation
nicht bewusst was passiert schon ein
bisschen spooky wie ich finde
ähnlich spannend aber auch ein
experiment russischer fachleute diese
konnten durch die hirnsignale ihrer
probanden und probanden herausfinden
woran diese denken zumindest hatten sie
hinweise dazu erhalten konkret lief
dieses experiment folgendermaßen die
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer schauten
youtube videos an die verschiedene
objekte zeigten darunter unter anderem
gesichter abstrakte formen oder aber ein
wasserfall
dabei trugen sie eeg kappe auf dem kopf
die es dem forschungsteam ermöglichten
schwache signale von der kopfhaut zu
messen damit konnten sie in echtzeit
bilder rekonstruieren die sich ihre
probandinnen und probanden anschauten
möglich wurde das durch ein neuronales
netzwerk das sie signal muster des
gehirns analysierte und auswertete und
so gelang es den russischen fachleuten
in 98 prozent der fälle die gedanken der
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer der
korrekten kategorie zuzuordnen war
wichtig an dieser stelle noch ist es
nicht soweit dass das netzwerk genau das
konkrete objekte herauslesen
es handelt sich also nicht wirklich um
gedanken lesen doch das experiment aus
russland offenbart dass die forschung
auf dem weg dorthin ist notwendig dafür
werden technologien die mit stärkeren
signalen arbeiten diese könnten dann
nämlich möglicherweise noch mehr
informationen aus dem gehirn muss dann
heraus lesen und die branche zeigt
großes interesse an dieser technologie
auch im fall der freiburger technik in
der aktuellen finanzierungsrunde kamen
13 millionen euro zusammen unter anderem
vom pharmaunternehmen und prothesen
herstellern auch nach ansicht von
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern ist die technik
erfolgversprechend in einem fachbeitrag
beschreiben kalifornische forscher diese
technik als relevant für die zukunft da
diese eine individualisierte therapie
mit minimalen nebenwirkungen möglich
machen der zweite geschäftsführer der
firma jörn rickert kam auf die idee
solch einen elektroden set zu entwickeln
als der epilepsie patientinnen und
patienten untersucht hatte epilepsie ist
wie ein ungewolltes gewitter in einer
gruppe von nervenzellen aber von patient
zu patient können es unterschiedliche
sein
man muss sehr exakt bestimmen um welches
gewebe es sich handeln weil die
betroffenen nicht mehr ausreichend auf
medikamente reagiert hatten blieb nur
noch die letzte möglichkeit die
entfernung von gehirngewebe so setzen
die fachleute also eine elektroden matte
ein die sie direkt auf das gehirn der
epilepsie betroffenen legten über
mehrere tage hinweg wurden die signale
gemessen
bei dieser untersuchung erkannte jan
richard etwas überraschendes alleine die
intention der betroffenen nun eine
computermaus bewegen zu wollen war in
den signalen zu erkennen und zwar bevor
das gehirn den entsprechenden befehl an
die finger geleitet hatte
auch wenn es sich nur um millisekunden
handelte machte es die beiden forscher
martin schüttler und björn rückhalt auf
ihre idee solche informationen und noch
tieferen nutzbar zu machen außerdem
schrieben sich die beiden auf die agenda
auf den umgekehrten weg zu analysieren
also passende signale zurückzuschicken
genau dazu hat vor kurzem ein
japanisches forschungsteam eine
spannende studie veröffentlicht diese
hatten epilepsie betroffenen ein ball
gezeigt und gleichzeitig bei den
patienten patienten auch bestimmte
gehirnareale aktiviert das führte dazu
dass die probanden probanden in den ball
ein
sein als das forschungsteam dann auch
noch einen hirnbereich aktivierte der
für die erkennung von farben wichtig ist
sah nie versucht teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer in der einen hälfte des balls
einen regenbogen zurück zum elektroden
netz von kottek die technologie
ermöglicht es daten aus 32 kanälen
aufzuzeichnen dass elektronen netz ist
bis zu 100 mikrometer dick klar ist je
feiner die elektronik ist umso
detaillierter kann sie nervensignale
aufnehmen oder diese an sie zurückgeben
und das bedeutet dann auch eine
zielgerichtete hirnstimulation es gibt
weitere firmen die auf eine ähnliche
technik setzen anfang des jahres hat
beispielsweise der
medizintechnikhersteller medtronic eine
zulassung in europa für ein ähnliches
gerät bekommen es handelt sich um den
presse pc neurostimulator der ein
sensorsystem besitzt das die
gehirnaktivitäten von parken sind
patientinnen und patienten mist doch
nicht nur hier sondern auch bei contact
fehlt noch eine entscheidende sache
die entschlüsselung der passenden
signale woran lässt sich also
beispielsweise erkennen in welchem
zustand eine krankheit gerade ist und um
sensorsignale von prothesen in das
menschliche bewusstsein zu bekommen
benötigt man wichtige informationen
welche signal muster und welche
hirnregionen rufen diesen sinneseindruck
hervor
menschen versuchen kommen dafür nicht in
frage die versuche von contact zu diesem
forschungsfragen werden deswegen
anschaffen durchgeführt stadt mit 32
kanälen wie content plant ihnen us-firma
neuerdings übrigens mit unglaublichen
3072 kanälen und das erfordert einen
krassen medizinischen eingriff der mit
vielen risiken verbunden ist eine
gigantische vision also die da in ihnen
mass kopf herumschwirrt dazu martin
schüttler
er nutzt zum beispiel zellophan
ähnliches material das die leitenden
drehte isoliert dessen beständigkeit
aber nicht erwiesen ist weil die
strukturen so fein sind muss ein roboter
her der extra dafür entwickelt wurde um
zu implantieren
und zwar statt eines einzelnen größeren
los viele kleine löcher eingebrannt mit
einem laser ein kopf wie ein sieb also
keine gute vorstellung doch schüttler
nimmt ihnen max ernst denn die
medizintechnik wird auf jeden fall davon
profitieren davon ist er überzeugt zitat
neuling bringt viele hochtechnologien in
einem see
10 zusammen spannende und auch ein wenig
beunruhigende zukunftsperspektiven sind
das und noch mehr zukunftsperspektiven
gibt es bei technology review
hier wird in jeder ausgabe in die
zukunft geschaut in zusammenarbeit mit
der redaktion ist dieses video
entstanden und exklusiv für klicks
umzuschauen de gibt es jetzt eine
ausgabe gratis klickt dafür einfach auf
diesen link her oder unten in die video
beschreibung können wir unser gehirn
hecken da gibt es noch mehr zum thema
von dr watson alias patrick also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
zwar doktor watson bis dann bleibt dran